[Music]
washington-dc the most heavily protected
city on earth
within its limits 177 foreign embassies
550 elected officials and 23,000
military personnel in the event of an
attack critical personnel are evacuated
underground shelters open while complex
defense systems patrol the sky but
nothing stopped the virus 27 days after
patient zero
Washington fell it began with riots on K
Street than shootings the National Mall
troops withdrew to bunkers civilians
were left in the streets America is on
the brink of collapse but some people
have survived Gardens grow on rooftops
their fences patrolled with rifles in
communities that live under constant
siege survival has taken the form of
urban warfare centuries ago on this very
soil brother fought brother spilling
blood to forge the United States history
is threatening to repeat itself now in
the heat of summer six months after the
outbreak began
a remnant of a corrupt state lurks in
the shadows ready to engage in a new
civil war agents of the division are the
only ones standing against it but how do
you save a nation when its enemies come
from within
[Music]
[Music]
you